les reprises pardon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup bonsoir
je dis
c'est génial aussi ce soir quelle soirée
d'ailleurs merci
oui smith a tout dit wow comme seul
qu'est ce qu'on peut ajouter à ça ça
pique
un peu de paix un peu d'amour bien plus
il en reste merci beaucoup
c'est un conte honneur d'être ici ce
soir notre
un grand honneur jeudi de remettre
un oscar à une des cinq l'amour et
talents qui sont nommés ce soir et qui
ont bâti leur carrière sur des
prestations surprenant
inoubliable et une mauvaise mais ce film
après film pouvait
leur
prestation d'actrice à l'honneur ce soir
l'ex sont autant de rappels figurent
parmi ce serait plus grandes actrices
avoir touché ce que le grand écran de
leur grâce et nommé dans la catégorie
meilleur
son